d'un enfant sur cinq en france est en
surcharge pondérale comment lutter
contre l'obésité infantile
à la veille de la journée nationale de
prévention visite dans une école
spécialisée où l'on applique quelques
bonnes recettes à villemur sur tarn
reportage frédéric montaigne monteil et
nicolas web ils ont troqué le crayon
contre le couteau la planche en bois
remplace le cahier et la copie se
déguste avec modération
au menu salade verte avec dés de fromage
et pignons de pin omelette aux oignons
et carottes cuites au curry en dessert
salade de fruits frais avec un péché
mignon du chocolat fondu bref le retour
à la cuisine d'antan
j'essaie d'un enfant une crudité un
légume cuit à midi et le soir de frais
par jour c'est suffisant et ça ça couvre
les besoins vitamines et de l'enfant en
six heures de cours ces enfants ont tous
appris à manger léger sauf arthur
concentrer sur sa bd à eux maintenant
d'éduquer leurs parents il ya de quoi
faire le vendredi et le samedi le
dimanche c'est quoi eh bien non la
tartiflette n'est pas vraiment
recommandé d'ailleurs lucas 11 ans le
sait bien
depuis plusieurs années il consulte un
pédiatre lui et sa famille ont changé
leur repas au côté souvent je conçois
des bateaux soient dû faire du chocolat
c'est que quand j'ai sport ou après ils
m'ont général sérieux fruits maintenant
j'aime simin à cuisiner un
approvisionnement des légumes frais une
à deux fois par semaine
attention pas de régime ou de sport à
outrance pour la famille manger mieux et
bouger plus suffit bien souvent le dakar
à présent direction l'argentine où de
nombreuses questions